today's video is brought to you by the
daily upside a free newsletter that's
delivering you financial news and
context to your inbox every weekday look
it's 2022 and you know what the deal is
with news it's pretty biased it's
untrustworthy it's also expensive every
time you go outside you're like oh hey
hey paywall how much i have to pay
okay no
it's time consuming it's somehow too
sensationalist and also it manages to be
boring all at the same time fortunately
there's the daily upside which was
founded in 2019 by a group of bankers
and journalists to provide fast easy
actionable insights into the world of
financial news every weekday before the
markets open the daily upside delivers a
morning briefing followed by more
detailed stories that are shaping the
business world and they go directly to
your inbox think of it as a five minute
brief to prime you on whatever you might
need to know for the day on top of that
they also write a deeper once a week
newsletter that explains more complex
business trends giving you that sweet
sweet financial knowledge you need to
sound smart at happy hour or you know
yeah i can use it for whatever you're up
to the daily upside is read by more than
300 000 subscribers including yours
truly right here because well fact boys
facts have to come from somewhere so if
you want to sign up for the daily upside
just click the link in the description
box below and you can get free daily
news sent straight to your inbox and of
course if you don't like it you can just
unsubscribe can't you simple brilliant
love it so yeah go check out daily
upside using the link in the description
below and now today's video
the battle of waterloo is one of the
most famous battles in world history
most everyone has heard of the dramatic
clash between the french emperor
napoleon and british duke of wellington
two of the most celebrated generals of
the age but there was a third figure
that was equally important in the
outcome of that battle and the war that
preceded it prussian field martial
gerber art von blucher had risen from
obscurity to become his nation's most
beloved soldier and everything he'd
experienced in his 72 years of life had
led him to this point to this dramatic
fight at waterloo the story of the man
known as marshall forward is a dramatic
tale one filled with glorious cavalry
charges political intrigue humiliating
defeat and ultimately victory and
redemption the battle over his legacy
has been at times as fierce as the
battles he fought against napoleon and
has certainly been coloured by modern
perspectives it's why despite being one
of the most important figures in the
podeonic wars he has almost been erased
from the public consciousness
[Music]
gearbarn liebricht von blucher was born
on december 16 1742 in the baltic port
city of rostock then part of the duchy
of mecklenburg early on it seemed
apparent that gabard along with his five
older brothers were destined for a
career in the military his father had
been a soldier and when you're a member
of the landless mine and ability fewer
the career paths were available
fortunately the constantly shifting
political landscape of 18th century
europe provided plenty of opportunity
for military-minded men the great powers
were constantly fighting each other for
influence and territory within the
dozens of minor principalities that make
up modern day germany in 1756 all of
europe went to war with great britain
and prussia on one side and france
austria and sweden on the other much of
the action in the seven years war was in
germany as all of prussia's neighbors
joined together in an attempt to bring
the upstart power to heel unable to
resist the promise of adventure
fifteen-year-old gebhard von blucher
joined the swedish army as a cornet or
ensign in 1758 he signed on with a
hassar regiment like cavalry which was
known for lightning pass raids behind
enemy lines riding and fighting hard and
well drinking and partying even harder
it's easy to see how a teenager would be
enamored by the glorious lifestyle of
the tsars even if the boy didn't speak a
single word of swedish in august 1760
during his third campaign with the
swedes the 17 year old blusher was
captured by prussian cavalry during a
reconnaissance mission rather than face
a long internment as a prisoner of war
the commander of the prussian regiment
convinced blush to switch sides and join
the prussian army instead having no
particular loyalty to sweden the boy
absolutely agreed and so he became
cornet blusher of the prussian cavalry
an association it was going to last for
the rest of his life lucia spent the
remainder of the war fighting with the
prussians and he remained in the army
even after the conflict ended he next
saw action in poland in 1769 when
prussia annexed the polish province
known as west prussia sending in troops
to back up their claim of sovereignty
initially giving credit for fighting
well captain bleisher found himself in
trouble along with the rest of his
regiment for his treatment of the native
poles including a priest that blusher
held a mock trial for and then pretended
to execute by firing squad
fortunately the guns were unloaded the
prussian monarch frederick the great
blamed regiment for bringing dishonor to
the prussian army and refused to
recommend any of its officers for
promotion being passed over rather
prickled the pride of the notoriously
sensitive blue shirt and in a rather
dramatic gesture he handed in his
resignation to the army to his surprise
it was actually accepted by frederick
who said that captain blue shirt can go
to the devil after 12 years of service
lucia was out on his ear
and it looked like his days of military
service were over
lucia decided to make a go of being a
country gentleman by all accounts he was
a successful estate manager and as
popular in the community of stargardt
today part of poland but he grew bored
with civilian life and he itched to put
his uniform back on and heft the sabre
once again starting in 1778 he began a
sustained letter campaign to king
frederick in an attempt to convince the
monarch to reinstate him letters took on
an increasingly pleading tone as the
years passed but
the king remained unmoved it was not
until frederick died in 1786 that
blucher entertained any real hope of
being reappointed to the army after
meeting and impressing the new king
frederick william ii blucher was finally
given a commission as a major in 1787
ending almost 15 years of exile blucher
was right at home in the army being
given command of a hussar squadron and
he was quickly promoted to lieutenant
colonel war broke out again in 1792
prompted by the extraordinary revolution
taking place in france in paris the
people of france had risen up to
overthrow king louis xvi installing a
republican form of government in the
monarchy's place this rather alarmed the
rest of europe's crowned heads including
austria and prussia who joined forces
and alliance to invade france and
restore louis to his throne along with
great britain and the dutch republic the
conflict became known as the war of the
first coalition one of seven coalitions
that would eventually be arrayed against
france over the following quarter
century for over two years the allies
and the french fought an inconclusive
series of campaigns against each other
on paper the overwhelming might of the
professional allied armies should have
decisively defeated a country where most
of their military officers have been
purged in the reign of terror but the
french were able to keep up thanks to
two factors they employed a levy on mass
a massive conscription program that
allowed france to deploy a far larger
army than any of our enemies and they
were also able to take advantage of the
fact that none of the allied countries
arrayed against them were able to put
aside their own individual national
interests in favor of defeating a common
enemy for instance the reason prussia
pulled out of the first coalition in
1795 was because king frederick william
needed his army to occupy precious
portion of the third partition of poland
both of these factors would work against
the allies throughout the napoleonic
wars for gerber dawn blush however the
war of the first coalition proved to be
very successful as a cavalry commander
he engaged in many successful scouting
and advanced guard operations on the
periphery of the main prussian army in
1794 he was promoted to major general an
honor that surely pleased the man for no
other reason that it promised additional
opportunities to get into the action
still blucher chafed at the unsatisfying
conclusion to the war with france and
itched for another chance to fight
against the french
ten years after prussia ended their war
with france the european geopolitical
situation had completely shifted the
french revolution ended with the rise of
general napoleon bonaparte who seized
power in a coup d'etat in 1799 napoleon
was quickly gaining a reputation as a
military commander without peer and the
popularity he had with the french
republic through his victories allowed
him to solidify his power by having the
pope crown a member of the french in
december 1804 at notre dame cathedral
napoleon was obsessed with the glory to
be gained on the battlefield and his
aggressive stance towards his neighbors
provided him with no shortage of enemies
to fight against in 1805 great britain
france's ancient enemy organized a new
coalition to try and curtail napoleon's
ambitions austria sweden and russia
joined the alliance but prussia remained
neutral once again national interest had
trumped pan-european interests napoleon
had built the most fearsome military
machine since the roman legions le grand
army its secrets lay in its complex
organization it was made up of seven
cores self-contained mini armies that
could be detached to fight as an
independent unit or combined together to
make an overwhelming force each one was
commanded by one of napoleon's marshals
his best generals who at times could be
almost as fearsome as the emperor
himself swollen to 250 000 men by the
levial mass and with the military genius
of napoleon commanding it the grand army
ran circles around the archaic armies of
the rest of europe whose organization
and tactics dated back to the
renaissance in the span of two months
napoleon completely destroyed the
austrian army he captured vienna and
then in december of 1805 he routed a
second army commanded by the russian
tsar and the holy roman emperor at
austerlitz considered one of the
greatest military victories in history
outlets effectively ended the third
coalition with the thousand-year-old
holy roman empire being broken up to
create a series of french client states
to act as a buffer between france and
germany and by the way if you'd like to
learn more about the battle outlets i've
done an entire video on that on probably
what is my newest channel wara graphics
i'll link to that below the encroachment
of french hegemony into germany greatly
alarmed the prussians and king frederick
william iii was finally persuaded to go
to war they joined the fourth coalition
alongside russia sweden and great
britain but because they waited so long
to get into the conflict they found
themselves essentially facing napoleon
alone with austria knocked out and
russia deep within their own borders
rebuilding their forces compounding
their era napoleon's army was still in
germany finishing their campaign from
1804 practically
right on prussia's doorstep what
happened next was almost inevitable in
just 19 days the french invaded prussia
shattered the prussians in the twin
battles of jenner and alstead and
captured berlin brush's losses were
staggering 65 000 casualties 150 000
prisoners on the death of two members of
the royal family frederick william fled
his capital and sought refuge with his
allies r alexander but napoleon was
close behind he caught up with the
russian army at friedland in 1807 and
destroyed it too forcing alexander to
sue for peace the treaties of tilsa were
particularly hard on prussia frederick
william was forced to give up half of
his territory and was hit with the bill
for 150 million francs as war
reparations with eastern europe pacified
napoleon departed with his grand army
invading the iberian peninsula in 1808
left in his wake was a prussia that was
just a shadow of its former self it was
completely humiliated
blusher was one of the few prussian
generals that had retained his honor in
the aftermath of the war with france 120
of his colleagues were either cashiered
or forced to retire as prussia sought to
place blame for the disastrous
performance of her army because of this
attrition blucher found himself one of
the most senior commanders left and he
itched for a chance to take revenge
allah hated napoleon prussia was in
absolutely no position to resume
hostilities instead the following five
years saw extensive work to reform and
modernize both the prussian government
and the military service in order to
match the sheer manpower deployed by
france the army was expanded from a
small cadre of professional soldiers to
a national service in which every
prussian man was expected to take part
reserve units called landfire were
raised all over prussia to complement
the active units this new army was going
to utilize the same organizational
structure and tactics that napoleon had
introduced in europe for years the
prussian king and his ministers waited
which chafed at the sensibilities of men
like blucher who wanted immediate war to
free their country from the french yoke
finally at the start of 1813 frederick
williams saw his chance the previous
june napoleon had led his grand army in
an invasion of russia while initially
successful winning battles at smolensk
and borodino the russians adopted a
scorched earth strategy as they
retreated further into the russian
interior evacuating moscow and leaving
it an empty shell for the french to
occupy in september lack of supplies
compelled napoleon to retreat which
quickly turned into a disaster as men
starved horses dropped dead and
relentless attacks from cossack cavalry
ground the grand army to dust then the
brutal winter set in and it froze what
was left of the army to death as many as
380
000 french soldiers were killed in that
campaign
napoleon's reputation for invincibility
had been absolutely shattered and
france's enemies saw that the time had
come to take him on prussia formed an
alliance with russia sweden and
eventually austria which was known as
the sixth coalition lucia now promotes a
field marshal was given command of one
of the three allied armies the army of
silesia the allies decided on a strategy
that hadn't been tried yet against
napoleon the emperor may be a fantastic
commander but the one thing he couldn't
do was be in more than one place at the
same time the three allied armies would
attempt to maneuver around napoleon
beating up on his subordinates and then
retreating before the emperor showed up
in this way they hoped to whittle down
his forces and lure him into a decisive
battle were they and not he
had the advantage for months bluesha and
the other commanders were engaged in a
cat and mouse game with their french
opponents inflicting defeats on his
marshals and compelling napoleon to
retreat to the city of leipzig where he
engaged the allies in a four-day-long
fight that would come to be known as the
battle of the nations over half a
million soldiers fought at leipzig and
there were 133 000 casualties the
largest european battle ever fought
before world war 1. by the end of it
napoleon had lost almost 80 000 and was
forced to retreat from germany
completely never to return after
negotiations and the war went nowhere
allies invaded france in january 1814
napoleon found himself beset on all
sides by enemies as the prussians the
russians the austrians invaded from the
east while a british army under general
wellington attacked from spain and the
south as the allies advanced on paris
napoleon and lucia fought a series of
battles that tactically were french
victories but strategically did little
more than delay the inevitable the fact
was the emperor was out of men out of
resources out of territory
and out of time on march 31st the allies
captured paris and a week later napoleon
abdicated the war it seemed it's finally
over
[Music]
peace could not have come soon enough
that the man his troops called marshall
forward the 71 year old general was both
physically and mentally exhausted from a
year of campaigning still recovering
from a battle wound and suffering from
various inflictions and ailments still
the old man was able to enjoy the spoils
of the victory that it played a crucial
role in winning over napoleon he was
showered with gifts and titles being
named prince blusher of wild starred by
king frederick william and traveling to
london to meet the british prince region
the future king george iv after his
victory lap as the allied army was being
stood down blucher returned home
preparing to retire from military
service but what would any great
performance ever be
without an encore in the 18th and 19th
centuries it was considered taboo to
execute a crown monarch even one you
were planning on deposing that was why
instead of killing napoleon after he
abdicated he was instead exiled to the
small mediterranean island of elba he
had no intention of staying there
forever though and on march the 1st 1815
he made his move escaping from elba and
landing in france with the force of a
thousand men in a bid to regain his
throne horses sent to capture him joined
with him instead and on march 20
napoleon was in paris proclaiming
himself emperor once again he claimed
that he wanted peace with the other
countries of europe but the allies
absolutely weren't having it they knew
that if he was allowed to remain in
power napoleon would eventually build up
his forces again and plunge the whole
continent back into war they declared
him to be an outlaw and a seventh
coalition comprising great britain
russia prussia and austria was formed to
stop napoleon blusher was named command
the prussian army the army of the lower
rhine currently assembling in belgium
throughout the brussels nearby was an
anglo-dutch army commanded by the
celebrated british general the duke of
wellington who had defeated the french
in the spanish front of the war the two
armies were to wait there for more
armies from austria and russia to arrive
and then they would all invade france in
concert on or about july the 1st
napoleon always in favor of bold action
wasn't going to sit around and wait for
that to happen yet assembled an army of
120 000 men mostly veterans of previous
campaigns in northern france the emperor
believed it was possible for him to
destroy first blusher and then
wellington as long as he could keep
their two armies from combining together
then after that he could deal with the
austrians and then the russians the key
to success was going to be speed
organization and audacity all hallmark
traits of the napoleonic style of
warfare
on june 15 napoleon surprised the allies
when he crossed into belgium at
charleroi in a position to divide the
two armies exactly what wellington and
blucher didn't want a flurry of messages
went back and forth working out the
allied response napoleon was going after
blusher first so he was going to make a
stand and wellington promised to march
to support him blusher positioned his
army in the village of ligne with three
of his four cores in position to meet
the french attack on june 16th two
battles were fought at ligni and quattro
brah as napoleon sought to destroy
blucher while sending marshall nay to
prevent wellington from supporting the
prussians at ligny napoleon and lucia
traded blows in a bloody affair that
caused 12 000 casualties on both sides
in the end napoleon emerged victorious
with an attack by his wanted imperial
guard proving decisive the latter stages
of the battle blucher's horse was shot
and collapsed on top of him crushing his
right leg and shoulder and trapping him
under his dead body his aid threw
himself on top of the field marshall and
dragged his cloak over him so his medals
would be hidden from passing french
cavalrymen who surely would have
captured him if they knew it was they'd
eventually got lucha off the battlefield
to join the retreat of his army in the
wake of the defeat napoleon detached a
third of his army under the command of
marshall graushi to chase the prussians
believing them to be going east he then
turned his attention to wellington's
army which had retreated after quattro
bra to a defensive position just south
of the village of waterloo but the
emperor who believed many to be the
greatest military mind since alexander
the great made a crucial mistake lucia
wasn't going east in the past napoleon
had exploited divisions within the
allied coalitions ranged against him
pitting one nation's interest against
another in order to thwart their
attempts to contain him but after over a
dozen years of war the other nations of
europe were united against the french
emperor above all else and what's more
they'd learned from past battles lucha
and wellington knew exactly what
napoleon was trying to do and responded
wellington made his stand a waterloo
because he knew the prussians were
coming to support him and blucher
instead of marching easter a group
instead went west because he knew
wellington was there
waiting for his help despite his
injuries the 72 year old general led the
charge pushing his army on relentlessly
over the next two days to come to
wellington's aid when he arrived late in
the afternoon on the 18th it couldn't
have come at a more fortuitous moment
wellington had been holding off attacks
from napoleon for hours but his lines
were starting to wear thin knowing that
blucher was coming the emperor had
thrown in his last reserve hoping that
the guard would break wellington's army
just like it had done at ligni and in
every other battle it participated in
dating back to 1805. lucia's advance
threatened napoleon's right flank
forcing him to detach troops from the
final assault to fend him off
desperately the emperor looked for
marshall grazie's troops but the marshal
was still following the prussian army
the back end of it that was in
accordance with napoleon's orders
kraushi was still
miles away from the battlefields
far too far away to be any help after a
brutal fight in the village of placenwar
blucher's troops succeeded in breaking
through the french lines as word of this
spread through napoleon's troops morale
plummeted they were exhausted from the
actions of the last four days and beset
on two sides all at once the emperor's
army disintegrated as soldiers broke and
ran including the guardsmen napoleon
himself only barely escaped capture
fleeing on a horse back to paris leaving
most of his opulent possessions to be
captured by the enemy within two weeks
he abdicated the throne again this time
for good the series of wars that had
begun almost without paws since 1792
were finally over
[Music]
despite calls from blusher and the
prussians have napoleon executed this
time he was exiled again
the remote south atlantic island of
saint helena guarded by british troops
he died there in 1821 eventually having
his body returned to paris for a hero's
burial it was the end of the campaign
for field marshal blucher as well he
retired to his estates in silesia living
comfortably until his death in 1819 aged
77. what is strange is that despite his
importance to world events he feels like
blucher has been almost lost to history
he's certainly less well-known than the
other two commanders of waterloo despite
all three of them ranking together as
probably the best generals of the
napoleonic period so what happened
unfortunately the blame for blush's
disappearance has more to do with his
descendants than the general himself
throughout the 19th century blucher was
revered as a hero by prussia their army
leadership which would end up being the
core of the imperial german general
staff after unification in 1871 modelled
themselves after marshall forwards and
planned battles based on the way that
they thought blucher would have fought
them during world war one anything and
everything associated with germany was
suddenly extremely unpopular in europe
and around the world the british in
particular who had spent the preceding
century arguing with their german
counterparts about which general was
more important to the defeat of napoleon
at waterloo did everything they could to
bury blucher in the pages of history
minimizing his impact on the war in
order to puff up their own national hero
wellington things got even worse after
the second world war when germany was
occupied and divided by the victorious
allies who did all that they could to
erase the influence of the prussian
military establishment that they
believed had led the world into war even
today with 80 years of separation from
that unhappy time there are few books
written in english about blucher's life
and campaigns outside of waterloo in
contrast to entire libraries of work
both dedicated to napoleon and
wellington it doesn't seem likely that
lucia himself would have cared very much
however in the anti-god he wanted a
lifetime of service in uniform the honor
and esteem of his country and most
importantly resounding triumph over his
most hated enemy
so i hope you enjoyed this video as i
mentioned in today's video i've got
another channel called war of graphics
where we deal just with surprise
surprise wars there's going to be a link
below thank you for watching